hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm a lot
of cool Ilana cool youtuber awesome
Channel
we're youtubers so I thought what better
thing to do than watch popular YouTube
videos right it's a theme we got right
right
Ryan right that's my name some people
think is Greg Alba I don't know all I
know is this Greg guy he is supposedly
ridiculously good-looking I heard it but
I don't know who he is
well if you gazed upon the face of Greg
Alba your eyes would easily melt they'd
melt just like Indiana Jones let's watch
this video she really paid attention to
that video April Fool's prank video take
it out oh yeah we're gonna watch the
Jennifer Aniston interview prank this
unbelievably Hollywood superstar
Jennifer Aniston has agreed to help me
it went so well he reacted like this
you're gonna love this so much because I
have asked Jen to play the role of worst
interviewee and Chris knew nothing about
it
here's what happened I need to keep my
voice down because I'm in a hotel room
right next to where Chris is
he has no idea I'm here Jennifer is just
been inside the chat and the question
that will set her off is your character
is quite forward if you want to make the
first move with a guy how do you do it
I've just taught it to be super super
mean and kind of horrible and just make
them look the most awkward into the USA
yes I've been so easy yeah we're kind of
yes the last time I saw you and I spoke
to you and then the video got something
about three million views it did which
is crazy
it actually done' right so I'm kind of
anxious about this one going as well
when Chris asked the question about
making the first move with a guy on a
date that's when Jennifer will switch
Horrible Bosses 2 CC backers dirty
dentist yeah
did you run pup the character even more
for the sequel I think we did we when
the writers sort of you know said to me
how far can we go yeah and I said take
it as far as you possibly can
okay I mean no harming and really go
just going for it we can we'll bring her
Raynor in do you need B I did you did
you find that you ever slipped into the
character Julia away from filming so
when you're at home well when you're out
partying
do you ever kind of really do try and
imagine Julia and then go out kind of
right thing and I don't raise it already
happen do you ever go to nightclubs I've
been to of course I've been denied yeah
it's not something I don't really
frequent them it's not really a Saturday
night thing and you know really fair
enough yeah your character Julius so
forward right arm interest is know how
you would make the first move if you
were if you wanted to with a guy how
would I make a first yeah that would you
I mean you're a famous is it really hard
for someone like you to make the first
move on a guy so like I don't know if
you're if you're out and about and you
you've started to see someone how do you
as a famous person let them know that
you like them is it is it tricular being
famous I mean it's it's I first of all I
don't think that's a extremely
appropriate question I just mean that
when yeah is it harder to do that being
famous or you know doing first dates and
things like that I mean you know it's
it's it's it's okay it's any question
that it'sit's silly it's a that session
it just feels like it kind of just seems
a little inappropriate don't answer them
please
you know what I mean just in terms of
like saying oh you hit on people notice
don't you want to doing a documentary
all about famous ease and love and
famous people in love and how it's
difficult and different so they asked me
to ask that question to you so sorry
about that
wait what so what was the exact question
I don't worry about it we move on it's
all fine
are you sure yeah absolutely sorry it's
all about like dating in the film it's
weird here and you say all the words all
the different words for and you know
blokes parts there's that one scene
where you were scrubs
oh yeah and have you ever thought about
writing your own erotic fiction you know
what Fifty Shades of Grey asked no no
are you the type of lady that's looking
forward to their Fifty Shades of Grey
film not really no I'm really bored you
tried what once writing about sick
fiction yeah I don't try I'm not I don't
write erotic fiction but you know I'm
sure I mean I think just what seeing
Fifty Shades of Grey will be interesting
just because of all of the the hype
around it yeah and I'm also what's
happening I just wanted to crush the
educators thank you so much for that I'm
here because we told Jennifer I'm so shy
just wanted to talk to you about all
these different things and I genuinely
was like I want this I want someone that
yeah
it was funny I thought could be a little
bit more ridiculous she could have done
a better job it could have been after
she liked yeah a good guy like intense
and scary and stuff like yeah I mean if
you're able to read into the subtleties
then yeah it's pretty funny but I
thought it's gonna escalate into
something like crazy and he seemed so
mad it was like mad about it he didn't
find him funny at all which just made me
feel really bad for this guy I thought
he was gonna cry when she he was like oh
you don't have to answer it yeah he
looked like he was gonna cry the whole
time with a little [ __ ] the poor guy no
he deserved it
look at him he's not Hollywood material
and we don't watch the green jacket was
really showing some Hollywood material
very clever very clever but I love
Jennifer Aniston I need I think she's
George she's gorge she's
there's not some complementary at all
gorgey ah yeah I don't know she's like
45 did you know that yeah and that's the
thing she looks great for 45 if I can
look that good F where do you find you
will I will sum well Greg Alba he'll
look good - who's Greg Alba
I think he's Jewish never seen him did I
mention that your eyes with Mel yeah
yeah they would mount but I I've never
seen him anyway guys if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects and Alana has a channel too
there's a lot of vlogs and and other
stuff there's a meme or skits included
getting ready for those so check out her
channel man
that was a kind of a disappointing video
I have to admit this one yeah I was like
laughing because I was like yeah wait
what I could say the worst prank I ever
did this is gonna make me look really
good in eighth grade my best friend went
to El Salvador and he called me this is
when myspace was popular and then he's
like he's like you should tell people
that I died that's a bad brain so I I
was in eighth grade this was years ago I
created a myspace post talking about how
this was around Christmas how there were
fireworks that went off and set their
home on fire the kids whose [ __ ] up I
have never come close to drink like that
ever since I was in eighth grade I
thought the stupidest [ __ ] was funny I
didn't realize how serious everyone
crazy it did not go over well yeah I
definitely ruined someone's Christmas
I remember oh I know a prank I pulled
actually that rhyme there back I was in
daycare I don't know how old I was and I
pulled the fire alarm
and now you say what happened after you
that's your prankster anyway guys I'm
caught up on the shoutouts so go to
facebook.com slash the real reject
shoutouts slash slash the real reject
shoutouts can you guess what the rest of
her ethnicity is the other 75% 25% is
black not making joke
take a guess and if you get it right
Alana will give you a kiss OH
take care now no no a real kiss on the
lips with tongue and everything